we're going to begin this hour with
anti-racist activist ibram X Kennedy who
is turning classic works by a literary
icon into books for children kindy is
adapting six of Zora Neal Hurston
stories into picture books illustrations
are so fantastic they come from
hurston's 1935 book of folk tales mules
and Men Candy's second book in the
series is called the making of
butterflies it's a story of how
butterflies were created here's a clip
of kendy's six-year-old daughter Imani
who's reading the book
that's how came came come
gorgeous butterflies of every color and
kind
oh I like that room setting ibra makes
candy is a CBS News contributor and also
the director of the center for
anti-racist research at Boston
University good morning go
congratulations to your favorite
daughter gorgeous is a big word when
you're six years old but you know what
um Abram I didn't read my first Zora
Neale Hurston book until I was in
college most people don't take on that
kind of literature until you're older
late late teens early 20s what made you
think you know what we should adapt this
as a children's book I mean that's the
reason same thing that's the reason I
didn't read the word okay so it wasn't
just me yes okay I was I had a daughter
of course I know of course we we have
many children here who why should they
not be reading one of the greatest sort
of writers and collectors of of folklore
in history what do you want kids what's
the message you want kids to get from
the making of butterflies
just the beauty of creativity and
creation and inventiveness and and just
for them to think about like how the
world came to be and everything in it
yeah you say there's also a deeper
message that adults can take away from
this
well I think that anything that can be
created can be recreated and so when
we're living in a world where certain
things we don't like how they've come to
be we as adults can can change it so
parents uh who in my experience do all
the shopping for kids you gotta see a
lot of kids walking through the aisles
that's true when they're under the age
of four maybe a little bit that's true
but so one thing that will happen right
when parents pick up this book is they
will notice that it's written in a style
you call ebonics which is a basically uh
African-American slang version of
English right uh why was it important
which is true to Zora's style of writing
why was it important to you to preserve
that
well first I mean Zora heard these folk
tales in Ebonics she wrote them
antibiotics and I think the tales would
have been lost there were certain
meanings within it would have been lost
if we didn't preserve the language
itself in which it was sort of carried
to people and and I also think it's it's
a way for people to to learn about a
different culture one of the ways you
learn about different cultures is
through learning about different
languages
so when parents are thinking about uh
and when they are reading this book with
children how would you recommend they
discuss with their children
um the importance of the
African-American vernacular and more
specifically its importance to African
Americans and culture and in history one
of the beautiful things about
African-Americans like like other groups
is we're incredibly diverse and so
they're people who speak different
languages so they're people who who
indeed in in the late 1920s they spoke
ebonics and told folk tales in that
language just as there were others who
who spoke English or French or
Portuguese and so that's one of the ways
to sort of this really speaks to the
diversity you know of the
African-American experience well help me
because I'm struggling here I confess
I'm struggling I'm such a stickler for
good grammar and I think when you're
teaching kids who don't like let me find
they're double they're double negatives
yeah they're well let me let me
variations on standard spelling yes yes
standard spelling yeah but okay I'd Mark
to pay age of course I don't have it
upstairs
um
wait a second wait a second wait a
second it says way after a while Dove
flowers de flowers wheeze put here to
keep dough World company but we Lonesome
ourselves I'm struggling because when
you're trying to teach kids at a young
age how to read quote proper English
isn't this confusing I get it because
all of us here know the difference but
when you're trying to teach children
is it not important that they learn
proper English this is what I'm
struggling and I don't want to be
insulting to what you're doing here no I
mean part of what what's happening
particularly with with young children is
they're learning to write and read
phonetically so they're sounding out
sounds and they're writing those sounds
so my daughter had just the experience
of learning watching her to learn how to
read and write particularly over the
last two years and initially she would
write out what she heard
spelling it out phonetics spelling it
out phonetically and indeed teachers
kindergarten first grade teachers
wouldn't correct students they want them
to sound it out and write it out in that
way so to me it both allows children who
are learning English to learn English
while simultaneously learning a
different language
different language that you see it is
that significant as there's English and
then there's the language of this book
yeah I mean that's what linguists say
you know language is a form of
communication with rules but you're
judged by language if you go out on a
job interview and you're not speaking
proper English you're really judged by
that or what is deemed proper English
what is deemed properly I know I'm
really hung up on this so that's why I
want you to help me get through this
and you know because I have a grandson I
reach them all the time
um but go ahead go ahead no and also
these are these are young children yes
and and you know these this is a board
book and we specifically made it a board
book but even four to eight-year-olds
who we may read this to 48 year olds
hopefully we're not judging 48 year olds
by by how they speak yeah and you've got
magnolia flowers also uh which is
another beautiful beautiful story buys
or new Anderson so
um this is an incredible series
beautiful book yeah yeah I love the idea
of it a lot
[Laughter]
the making of butterflies is on sale
today wherever you like to buy yourself
it'll make you think it'll make you talk
for sure yeah absolutely yes because
we've been talking about it all morning
all morning